(bright music)
Always a good day is Dr. Garry, though.
He's gonna take over now as we talk about fracture care.
Thank you, Joseph.
Thank you, David.
Okay, so we're gonna talk about some pediatric fractures
and then adult fractures.
I would, for those of you that,
particularly who are gonna take the exam,
please pay attention to the supplemental slides
about complications of bracing and casting
as well as stress fractures, okay?
All right, so let's get started.
If I'm concerned about a fracture, my first line is X-rays,
and generally I want three views
to be able to identify what's going on,
an AP, a lateral, and an oblique in general terms.
My second line is non-contrast MRI for fracture assessment
if that's what I need.
There's a caveat to that and that's a non-contrast CT.
So in two fracture types,
I want a non-contrast CT as my second line.
Intra-articular distal radial fracture that's displaced.
So I see that on X-ray.
I want to be able to get a better idea
of the degree of displacement of that
and a tibial plateau fracture, okay?
These, they're prone to
developing osteoarthritis post-fracture.
So I want to optimize my treatment of those
and surgical decisions will be made based on the CT.
So if you're concerned about it,
get the CT as you're referring them to the orthopedist,
if that would be your next step,
so that they have all the information
at the time they see the patient.
Pediatric fractures,
roughly 1/3 of them are gonna involve the growth plate.
Roughly 1/3 of them are gonna involve the fingers.
And it's relatively uncommon
that you're gonna have a growth deformity
as a result of a pediatric fracture.
Again, if you suspect a fracture,
get radiographs in this population
primarily because of the open physis.
We're gonna see a bit of a caveat about that
when we talk about the ankle.
And then they always like to ask
some kind of question about
you have some intra-articular fracture in this 8-year-old
or 7-year-old or 12-year-old
and that intra-articular fracture is gonna be displaced.
So what are you gonna do with it?
Well, again, because we're trying
to preserve the joint in pediatric and adolescent patients,
particularly with open growth plates,
we're almost always going to have an open reduction
and internal fixation
for any displaced intra-articular fracture.
Whether it's the toe, whether it's the hand,
the elbow, the knee, wherever it may be.
Here are your Salter-Harris classifications.
Remember type one is a fracture through the physis.
Type two is the most common type.
I would pay attention to that most common type
that you're gonna see
through the physis and then up into the metaphysis.
Type three and four are intra-articular.
So these almost always end up at a surgeon
because they're gonna need a pin or a wire in them
to optimize the joint.
And then type five is a crush injury.
Okay, so let's go into some specific fractures
and specific things I want you to pay attention to.
The supracondylar fracture,
five to seven or eight-year olds,
they fall on an outstretched hand.
We call that a FOOSH injury.
We're gonna see a lot of that in this talk.
So I'm just gonna refer to it as FOOSH injuries.
These kids are gonna present usually with a painful elbow.
They don't want to move it,
and they may have already ecchymosis, tenderness,
and or swelling in the antecubital fossa.
You'll get your radiographs to look for this.
If you have anything other than a non-displaced fracture,
that would be a type one.
Anything else by general standards
will be referred to an orthopedic surgeon, okay?
Any kind of displacement would get referred.
In my experience, most family medicine physicians
aren't really all that comfortable
taking care of supracondylar fractures period,
even if they're completely non-displaced.
But if it is non-displaced, put 'em in a long arm cast,
recheck them in one week, and then three weeks.
Again, as long as they remain non-displaced,
they can be treated.
What I want you to pay attention to
is the most commonly entrapped nerve
in a supracondylar fracture
is the anterior interosseous nerve, okay?
That overlaps with the median nerve
so that if they can make an okay sign,
the anterior interosseous nerve is intact.
On your lateral film of the elbow, you have fat pads.
And remember, you see the outline
of the anterior fat pad here.
It's the blacker shading
because there's fluid in the joint,
and so it pushes the capsule out anteriorly.
And so you get this darkness
or this black, degree of blackness anteriorly.
That's suggestive of a fracture.
If I see that on a plain film, I'm thinking, okay,
maybe an intra-articular fracture involved here.
If the posterior fat pad is involved,
and here I see the posterior fat pad,
that blackness should be adherent
to the posterior humerus, but it's not.
It's migrating out posteriorly
because there's fluid in the joint,
then that's really pathognomonic
of an intra-articular fracture.
So I need to treat them as a fracture,
even though I don't see it on my radiographs.
I bring them back in a week, and I repeat my radiographs,
and there's that supracondylar fracture, okay?
So now you can either decide you're gonna treat this
if it's a type one, or you're gonna refer them on.
In pediatrics, in an acute elbow injury,
if they're unable to extend the elbow fully,
that is associated with elbow fractures.
So be aware of that.
Here's a buckle or torus fracture.
This is about 50% of all wrist fractures that occur.
What's new?
You've all seen this.
Assuming I have a reliable parent, okay,
this is what you're gonna do.
You put 'em in a soft wrist splint,
you tell 'em to keep that on for three weeks.
In three weeks, the parent just palpates the area.
If the kid's okay, take off the splint and let 'em go, okay?
There is no return to the office.
There is no repeat radiographs,
there is no casting that's involved, okay?
That is new.
And you see the choosing wisely with the data
that's come out on that now too.
Okay, so our first question.
A 3-year-old male is brought to your office by his mother
to evaluate his left arm,
which he stopped using earlier today
after walking home with his mother from preschool.
He cries when the elbow is manipulated
and keeps his left arm at his side.
Elbow radiographs are negative for fracture.
Using an evidence-based approach to your patient,
which would be the most successful initial treatment.
Okay, hyperpronation, terrific.
Flexion supination is what 60% of us in here
probably learned when we were training.
Now hyperpronation is what can be used.
This is nursemaid's elbow.
Remember, these are your toddlers.
It's a traction injury to the elbow.
Typically when you're holding the hand,
pulling the toddler toward you
or keeping them from running off someplace
and you support the elbow, take the hand,
and pronate it all the way over
while you're supporting the elbow,
and you can feel the radial head,
and you get all the way over,
and you'll feel it pop right back in, okay?
That's first line treatment.
And frankly is easier for someone who's done both.
Many times the hyperpronation is a lot easier.
Clavicle is the most commonly fractured bone in the body,
and virtually all of these occur in the middle third.
So what you want to do
is you're gonna put individuals in a sling.
You do not need to put them in a figure eight.
You can,
you do not need to
because the outcomes are equivalent
whether you put an individual in a figure of eight
or you put them in a sling, okay?
So sling is generally preferred.
Okay, our next question.
A 44-year-old female tripped and fell on the ice
on an outstretched left hand, another FOOSH injury.
She presents with this radiograph.
So the question is,
what is the most commonly injured nerve in this injury?
Is it musculocutaneous, median, radial, or ulnar nerve?
Okay good, median.
Not radial, but let's talk about what we have,
a distal radial fracture.
So roughly one in five fractures that we see in adults
are distal radial fractures.
Far and away the most common etiology
is osteoporosis.
So we should just define a fragility fracture.
Fragility fracture is one of the,
a fragility fracture in a postmenopausal female
or a male over 70 is a clinical diagnostic indicator
for osteoporosis.
A fragility fracture is,
I'm walking down the street,
and I trip, and I fall, and I put my hand out, okay?
If I'm 25, and I break my wrist, I broke my wrist.
If I'm a postmenopausal female or a male over 70,
and I do that, it's a fragility fracture.
It's a fracture that occurs from a standing height.
I did not fall off a ladder, I did not fall off the roof.
I did not fall out of my deer stand
or wherever I was.
There's no trauma, so to speak, that's involved
short of falling from a standing height.
So that's our diagnosis of fragility fracture.
It's important because you're gonna see a theme here
about assessment of bone health for individuals.
It's important because if I have that history,
I want an assessment of bone health.
DXA, okay?
All right, so for these,
median nerve is the most commonly involved nerve entrapment
that occurs with distal radial fractures.
And remember, if I have an intra-articular fracture,
and it appears that I have even one to two millimeters
of displacement along the articular surface,
I want a non-contrast CT.
I can get the non-contrast CT.
And if I think, you know, I'm not comfortable handling this,
I'm gonna send it on to the orthopedic surgeon,
get the non-contrast CT before their appointment,
so that they can make the decision
because that's the next step.
Okay, and this I would give to you,
this is gonna be covered elsewhere this week,
but I would give you this to print off and study.
There are oftentimes lots of questions
with regards to innervation of the hand itself.
So you have that.
Okay, our next question.
A 36-year-old female presents to your office
and reports that she had a FOOSH injury
in the left hand three days ago,
presents with left wrist pain,
minor swelling in this radiograph.
So take a look at it, and then I'll ask you a question.
Okay, what's the best treatment option?
You're gonna refer her for surgical fixation,
put her in a volar wrist splint for eight weeks,
a short arm cast for eight weeks,
or a thumb spica cast for eight weeks.
Good, thumb spica cast.
So right, this individual had
a non-displaced scaphoid fracture of the,
we would call this the waist
of the waist of the scaphoid fracture.
So in terms of scaphoid fractures,
yes, they occur with FOOSH injuries.
Yes, I generally have minor swelling, but I have pain.
Remember that I am tender in the anatomical snuff box
and my initial radiographs may well be negative,
and if they are but I suspect this,
then I must put them
in some kind of thumb spica splint, cast, something,
to immobilize that area, and then bring them back
and repeat radiographs in one to two weeks.
And remember that the scaphoid blood supply
is distal to proximal.
So I really like those distal fractures
because they heal more quickly.
They have a lower tendency to non-union, they do better.
The proximal fractures are the ones
that have a higher propensity to non-union
and higher propensity toward avascular necrosis.
That's a problem.
Okay, no clear benefit to operative intervention
of an acute non-displaced scaphoid fracture.
But if I do have some displacement,
I want to get them referred to surgery
because fixation is really the faster recovery method.
It's simply, it's a tiny little incision
and a screw that goes in.
It's less than a 15 minute surgery, right?
It takes an hour to get 'em into the OR,
it takes 'em 10 minutes to do the surgery.
It takes 'em one or two hours in recovery when they're done.
Okay, so our next question,
a 17-year-old football player comes to clinic
the morning after a game
in which he injured the ring finger of his right hand.
He grabbed the jersey of an opposing player
as he tackled him
and immediately felt pain in the distal aspect
of the affected finger.
On examination, there's mild swelling of the finger,
and he cannot flex at the distal interphalangeal joint.
Radiographs show a small bony fragment
at the volar surface of the proximal distal phalanx.
So our question,
which of the following is the most appropriate management
for this individual?
Are you gonna refer him to a hand surgeon?
Are you gonna splint
the distal interphalangeal joint in flexion
for eight weeks,
splint the distal interphalangeal joint
in extension for eight weeks,
or splint the proximal interphalangeal joint
in extension for six weeks,
followed by night splinting for another four to six weeks.
Okay, so about half of you want to send to the hand surgeon,
which would be correct.
We're gonna move right on into another finger question.
A 33-year-old male presents
with suspected dislocated finger.
He was playing volleyball the previous day
when he jammed his left fifth finger.
On examination, the distal interphalangeal joint
to the left fifth digit has full passive range of motion,
but he cannot actively extend the distal phalanx.
A radiograph of the digit is normal.
Which of the following is now most appropriate
for this individual?
Okay, terrific, so we got these, all right,
and we'll just briefly talk.
The first one was jersey finger.
It's an avulsion of the flexor digitorum profundus tendon.
It's a flexor tendon.
It tends to retract, you can't immobilize and get healing.
So these are surgical cases,
and we do wanna pay attention to this.
If they're three weeks out, it's a done deal.
There's no surgery to be done typically.
You can't stretch that muscle back out
to be able to reattach it.
So we really want to get these individuals into the OR,
the sooner the better
but certainly within the first two weeks.
A Boutonniere deformity,
this is a central slip injury of the finger
where the lateral extensor bands
at the proximal interphalangeal joint,
they sublux over the joint.
They gradually pull
that proximal interphalangeal joint into flexion
and then subsequently the distal interphalangeal joint
into extension or hyper extension,
yeah, in kind of a hyperextension of the joint,
the joint itself,
even though the distal aspect comes into extension.
So if I have this,
and it takes time for these to develop,
then what I do is I work at getting
the proximal interphalangeal joint
splinted into a neutral position
or a straightened out position
trying to get that flexion out of it.
And this is a case where I'm gonna splint that joint
for a period of time,
and then I'm gonna follow it with night splinting
for a period of time.
And the last one's the mallet finger.
And the mallet finger,
I have avulsed that extensor digitorum tendon.
We've all seen this.
And so for these, I want to immobilize
only the distal interphalangeal joint only
in extension or hyperextension if I can a little bit,
and I'm going to keep them fully immobilized
for a period of six to eight weeks
before I ever remove the splint.
This is where if your patient comes back
and they say, well, Doc,
I changed this splint myself at home,
and I took it off
and then I did some things around the house,
and then I put it back on.
You're starting over from the time they did that, right?
We reset the clock from that standpoint.
Okay, this is for your clinical practice.
You can print this out.
You've got your finger injuries, your exam, management,
and then if you have any referrals
that we would make based upon that.
Okay, so let's move ahead to another question.
A 74-year-old female patient with hypertension,
osteoporosis, and arthritis is seen for routine follow up.
She notes an increase in her back pain about two months ago.
She denies any trauma or associated symptoms.
Her medications include a thiazide, a bisphosphonate,
a proton pump inhibitor, and a non-steroidal.
Her exam is unchanged
other than some mild diffuse low back tenderness.
You obtain this radiograph.
So I'll give you a minute to look at this radiograph.
She's had an increase in back pain about two months ago.
Okay, so the question is,
which of the following statements is correct?
She has an increased mortality rate of 15%
over those without this condition,
she will need to be evaluated for multiple myeloma,
this is going to require surgical intervention,
or 20% of these remain undiagnosed.
Okay, so the correct answer is A,
and we're gonna go over this.
This is a vertebral compression fracture at L1.
So we want to pay attention,
vertebral compression fractures
because of the mechanics of the spine
occur pretty consistently between T8 and L2 and then L4.
Those are the vertebra that we're really looking at.
Osteoporosis, osteoporosis, osteoporosis.
And then the fourth leading cause is not osteoporosis,
it's osteoporosis risk factors, okay?
All right, so you have that.
Not 20% of these remain undiagnosed,
but 66 to 67% remain undiagnosed.
Why?
Because our elderly patients think chronic pain
or pain is part of the normal aging process.
So they tend not to bring this to your attention.
They don't come in to say,
oh, well you know, my back's been hurting more.
Well, I'm getting old, I have aches and pains.
This is just part of that process.
And that's why so many of these are undiagnosed.
Why do these individuals have higher mortality?
Because when we have
thoracic vertebral compression fractures particularly,
we tend to have a bit more of kyphosis
that develops over time.
Again, you've seen this in your patients,
and they develop restrictive pulmonary disease,
and that's a problem, especially as we get older.
And then some of these are gonna occur
because there's underlying malignancy.
So individuals with vertebral compression fractures,
particularly elderly,
have a higher risk of mortality than those without this.
Okay, so what do we want to do
with the vertebral compression fracture?
These are really key points
and I want you to know each one of these inside and out.
You're gonna manage pain
so you can get them moving as quickly as possible,
hopefully within 24 hours.
So if it's somebody that I have to admit to the hospital
because they're in so much pain,
I want to address that pain as quickly as possible
so I can get them up and moving.
This is the one place
in an osteoporotic vertebral compression fracture,
it's the one indication for the use of calcitonin.
We use nasal calcitonin,
gives moderately good pain relief.
The second thing
that I want you to pay attention to and know
is that if I have an individual who has a fragility fracture
and this vertebral compression fracture
would count as a fragility fracture, no trauma,
I'm postmenopausal female or a male over 70,
and I sustain a vertebral compression fracture,
you need to evaluate their bone health.
And we do that by getting a DXA.
And third, when we use bisphosphonates,
we essentially put a five-year limit on our use.
And that's a total limit over lifetime.
Otherwise, as I go beyond that,
I have marked increase in my atypical femoral fractures,
particularly for these individuals.
Okay, I do wanna mention pelvic insufficiency fractures
because you also see these.
It's again, osteoporosis, osteoporosis, osteoporosis
are causes for these.
Individuals who sit down a little too hard.
They may have missed the edge of the bed
as they're sitting down,
but they say, don't worry, Doc,
I lowered myself down to the ground.
And they come into the ER,
they come in, or into our office in a wheelchair,
but by the time we see them, examine them,
and try and get them up to walk, they can't walk
because it's too painful.
Get radiographs for these individuals.
If the radiographs are negative, but you still suspect this,
or you have osteopenia on your radiographs,
then you have to decide between a CT or a MRI.
And a CT is good.
I mean it's markedly better than radiographs.
It's good, but you're just gonna have to make that decision.
Do I need to wait a couple hours and get the MRI,
or do I get the CT, and I'm done in 15 minutes?
And you kind of have to decide,
am I gonna have to admit this person in the first place?
I've already gotta admit 'em, maybe I'll go with the CT,
I'll presumptively make the diagnosis if the CT is negative.
You just have to make those decisions.
But remember, MRI is still the premier exam
for osteoporotic pelvic insufficiency fractures.
Think about getting a baseline hemoglobin when they come in,
especially if you're admitting them,
so that you can measure it the following day
because they can put one
or two units of blood here in the pelvis.
So again, pay attention to that.
Realize that you're immediately looking for subacute rehab
or transitional care for these individuals
because their average length of stay is 14 to 45 days
before they can consider returning home.
And again, work-up for osteoporosis.
A few comments about hip fracture
almost always caused by falling directly onto the hip.
And not a surprise that it affects women more.
Women live longer than men.
Women have a higher rate of osteoporosis than men.
And so here's the data.
What we really want to do,
if I could impact you any way in terms of your practice,
your clinical practice,
this is where I would try and impact you.
This is prevention of the hip fracture in the first place.
So keeping our patients active, keeping them exercising,
keeping them strong, so that they can maintain balance
and paying attention to bone health in our patients.
Why?
Because when I take a group of patients who,
a group of individuals who are living independently, right,
in their own homes with their spouse,
by themselves, with others,
and they sustain a hip fracture, okay?
1/3 of them are gonna be dead within a year
related to that hip fracture, okay?
1/3 of them will be dead.
Tang's data is the newest.
He had 37% die within the first 6 to 12 months
developed a pneumonia,
they developed a DVT PE is a complication of it,
I had a postoperative complication, et cetera, et cetera.
But 1/3 of 'em are dead within a year.
And another roughly 30% are going to a nursing home
and staying in a nursing home.
So my outcome is 60%, right?
Roughly 30% are gonna be dead
and 30% are gonna be in a nursing home
from people who are living independently.
So if I can prevent that hip fracture,
I should be able to keep
that individual in their home living independently.
And I think that's something
we really want to pay attention to.
Okay, our last question here.
Which of the following is not a factor
in the Ottawa Ankle Rules?
Okay good, so the anterior distal fibula, right?
The Ottawa Ankle Rules say I should be looking
at the posterior distal fibula.
So you've got this.
These are mostly non-displaced fractures.
If I have malleolar fractures,
if it's one, put 'em in a boot, keep them comfortable,
or a short leg cast.
If it's two or three, remember I have a third malleoli,
the posterior malleolus.
If I have two or three,
generally it's gonna be referral to a surgeon
because they generally are unstable
and might need to have a few of them fixed.
Here are your Ottawa Ankle Rules.
Again, I would print this out, I would pay attention to it.
I would read it carefully.
Understand it if you don't use it,
but half of you do, and you know it.
So that's great.
Again, this just talks about
the malleolar fractures in a boot.
If I have a posterior malleolar fracture,
I start with four weeks of non-weight-bearing in a boot
or a cast,
and then I transition to weightbearing
once I start having a little bit of healing.
The proximal fifth metatarsal,
if I have a tuberosity fracture that's in the purple region,
do what you want with it, put 'em in a boot,
put 'em in a cast shoe, wrap 'em up.
I mean, whatever makes them comfortable enough to walk on it
because they're gonna heal.
If they're in the metaphyseal-diaphyseal junction,
that's a Jones fracture.
They have a 50% non-union rate.
So these individuals have to be non-weight-bearing
for four to six weeks,
demonstrate that they have some healing on radiographs,
and then transition them to weight-bearing.
Typically, we'll send 'em to orthopedics,
again, a 10 minute operation, small incision,
put a screw in, you're all done.
And you don't have that risk of non-union that occurs.
And the last, this is our last slide, radial palsy,
radial nerve involvement is radial palsy,
and that is crutch palsy that can occur.
And that's from the improper fitting of crutches, okay?
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Dr. Gary.
(audience applauding)
(bright music)